hello hello again it's fluted here I
wanted to make a quick video about the
role of the language teacher nowadays
and and I just want to share my opinion
with you about subject oh well I think
first of all that the main language
teacher might be able to misleading in
the sense that I am convinced vertically
convinced that nobody can teach your
language you have to learn by yourself
the fact of the name the reason why I
think that the name is misleading is
because a lot of students have no
experience of language learning and
think that it is the teacher who has to
help not not only help them but just
teach them the language I'm also
convinced that deliberate teaching has
nothing to do with language learning if
you are deliberately teach the language
to somebody you're not going to succeed
if that person is successful in language
is is because they want to learn it's
not being taught and this is the first
thing that I my first Indiana
the second one is that you know I as far
as I am concerned I wouldn't French at
school I will say that I learn Frances
school but is not is not true the real
place where I learned French is not
school it was how was by watching movies
what's by reading a lot of books was but
doing homework the homework that my
teacher gave me and whereas a lot of my
my friend then do anything about it I
just I just put my head to it I just
want to learn this at the homework and
kept doing all these independent
activities that virtualize my success in
learning French the thing is though that
my teacher was very motivating
she was very passionate about what she
did and this gave me the motivation to
keep going she and this is not only like
my English my French teacher but also my
American plan same thing the real the
real importance of these teachers was
essentially the fact that were very
motivating and this kept me going
because you know takes a little bit of
times and he has to be a little
discipline these regard but is me 90% of
the pork they just check the work is
that hey way to go or good job and just
give me extra motivation what I wanted
to say that the main role of a language
teacher I wouldn't call them that I
would call them the language manager or
a language consultant as it is called
out in some calling out a the main role
of the language manager is to get to
motivate he has to give you motivation
and but not only that the problem is
that when if the Internet has serious
nowadays the main resource for a lot of
length learners independent lens
learners and only independent learners
and the reason why the language manager
role the language manager it has become
so important right now is that because
they have to be a guide it is not just a
matter of motivating it's important to
motivated it's essential but it is also
important to guide somebody like normal
language learners in the process in the
dungeon of all the resources that exist
on the Internet the main problem is that
a lot of people they study they learn
with a disordered way they don't have
discipline but I don't even have the
structure and you're learning and it
doesn't help in this regard because they
just think big up things here and there
buying websites and they just jump from
one website to the other this leads to
miss do
- confusion so I think there the
language we have to battle the Council
of language language teacher we have to
embrace the concept of language manager
I is I consider myself a language
manager in the sense of people who ask
me for information how to learn the
language I guide them through the
process I tell them how to start and
then I follow them so that they can
progress and believe in themselves which
is very important in psychological
factor is absolutely a sense the
attitude and psychological this
psychology this frost absolutely
important so this is my vision that I
wanted to share with you and thank you
for listening bye